noam chomsky professor of linguistics at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology this evening in Washington
speaking to a group they've asked you to
come talk about the implications and
consequences of the Clinton
administration's foreign policy
how's Bill Clinton done first year in
foreign policy I think about as expected
I actually wrote an article last
December about it my view is that he was
exactly the way he presented himself
candidate of big business new democrat
free from the old liberal cliche is
about entitlements and rights and so on
committed to improving the business
climate to engaging the government more
in supporting the wealthy the kind of
thing he'd done in Arkansas and I think
that the both the formulation of the
policy which came in late September
there was a series of speeches in which
the Clinton vision as they were calling
it was formulated and then the
achievements of the policy which are
essentially the November achievements
NAFTA the the Asian Pacific Council
summit associated domestic programs that
reflects his achievement in supporting
the concerns and interests of major
American corporations it explains why
the Wall Street Journal for example was
so enthusiastic about him describing him
as a continuing with what has been a
pattern of democratic presidents who
linked up very closely to interest of
big business rather than a small
business whereas the Republicans in
contrast tend to be the party of the
business community generally so somewhat
different and I think that's pretty much
what we're finding and we will continue
to find I think with the health plan and
so on on the other hand and other
foreign policy issues such as you know
I'm say helping restore democracy in
Haiti and so on I mean I never expected
any possibility of that and don't see
any if if you mentioned some of those
the foreign policy achievements go back
and talk a little bit more detail you
mentioned NAFTA
right off to that you know going to that
well further about the impact NAFTA is
going to have well and after there's a
good deal of the issue that was
discussed like will there be more jobs
or less jobs
there's nobody has any idea none of the
economic models that are being used
they're so remote from reality that what
they say is almost meaningless and
that's pointed out a long time ago the
Congressional office of Technology
Assessment did an analysis of this
executive version of NAFTA about a year
ago and made that point among others
however there are some consequences
about which there's pretty general
agreement then if you read the text and
you see the international forces at work
you can understand what it is going to
have the effect of deepening the split
between the the wealthy and the general
population now inequality has been
growing in the country for about thirty
years real wages have been declining
growth has been quite slow such wealth
has been created is going increasingly
through a small sector of the wealthy
the country is kind of taking on a sort
of a third-world look and it's not
Brazil or Mexico but if you walk through
the streets of any major city say
Washington or New York or whatever you
see what the statistics tell you that
there's a large relatively marginalized
population developing superfluous for
wealth production because increasingly
transnational corporations are able to
shift reduction to high repression in
low-wage areas elsewhere and wages will
go down in fact they're going down
internationally because these things all
interact so as American way of the u.s.
wages are now the lowest in the
industrial world outside of Britain
that's a big change over the last ten
years in fact a complete reversal and
that means that say German factories
will invest in Alabama as they're now
doing because they get much cheaper and
more request labor so it brings down
German wages Matiz it anticipated from
NAFTA
I think almost across the board it
is a lowering of the income of a
substantial part of the population
probably a majority an increase in
wealth for privileged sectors and what
that will mean overall in the statistics
is not so certain so let me give you one
one analysis which is highly regarded
and taken actually here in the
Washington Post is by a UCLA professor
of management Edward leemer who's prone
F that I believe and he estimated that
by the end of the decade if NAFTA goes
through in the present form the form
that it did go through there would be an
increase his estimate was of about three
thousand dollars a year in income for
professionals and ASEC people associated
with the higher levels of the business
community managerial skilled labor
executives and so on about $3,000 a year
increase in income for them about a
seven hundred and fifty dollar a year
decline in income for most of the
workforce and he figured that would
average out to about a two hundred
dollar a year decline for the general
population and my believe he's Pro NAFTA
and most of the economists were prone
enough to say something similar so my
colleague Paul Krugman of MIT is a
international trade specialist who's
very Pro NAFTA does agree that for
unskilled labor there will be a decline
in income unskilled labor happens to be
70% of the workforce there was an
analysis in the New York Times the day
after the NAFTA vote they delayed it
it's the first analysis of the regional
impact of NAFTA predicted regional
impact in the New York area and it was
exactly the same
there's a banking corporate law firms
the pharmaceutical corporations of the
publishing industry chemical industry
which is highly capital intensive not
many workers corporate law firms own
they'll all do fine then they said
there'll be some losers the losers will
be women blacks Hispanics semi skilled
labor that's about three-quarters of the
workforce and the effect will be to
split to increase intensify
the move that is very clear towards
separating the society at the two tiers
in the long term it means sort of
internationalizing the third world model
that's the typical third world country
say Mexico you know small sector of very
wealthy people usually connected to
international investment than finance
and transnationals and so on and a very
large sector of extremely poor people
and that instantly NAFTA's expected have
the same effect in Mexico so the leading
Mexican financial journal which is very
Pro NAFTA estimated that about 25
percent of Mexican manufacturing
industry would be destroyed in the first
two years and about fourteen percent of
the workforce would be eliminated
another effect of NAFTA which everyone
expects is that cheap US agribusiness
exports will contribute to the process
oil already going on of driving out
large numbers of peasant producers all
of this swells the workforce swelling
the workforce drives now an income there
is no serious opportunity for organizing
it's pretty repressive and brutal so
they'll have the effect of lowering
wages they're just as we'll have the
effect of lowering wages here and this
if you look at the international system
this is a continuing drag any country
that's providing more where workers have
achieved more right say rights to hold
job security or pension rights or
whatever it's naturally going to be
driven down as international capital can
seek the point of highest repression and
lowest wages so where you move towards
an international economy of essentially
low growth low wages and very high
profits and that's a kind of
internationalization of the third world
model and this particular version of
NAFTA was is very likely to have that
consequence no you know it should not be
called a free trade agreement because it
is not it is a highly protectionist
agreement with a complex mixture of
liberalisation and protection designed
to guarantee investor rights investor
are very delicately protected worker
rights community rights and so on are
undercut in fact one consequence of it
is to attack democratic institutions as
a mystery at it places decision-making
power in the hands of unaccountable
structures which are transnational if
there's a conflict let's say between
some local or regional decision on say
environmental protection or pesticides
or whatever and in a transnational
corporation that will ultimately find
its way to an adjudication panel which
operates in secret which is made up
mainly of corporate lawyers and so on
and is out of public control all of
these systems reduce the role and
effectiveness of parliamentary
institutions and unions and other
popular groups and increase the
decision-making power of investors and
transnational corporations and big banks
and so on and that's what they're
intended to do good afternoon and
welcome to a special LIVE viewer callin
program on this Friday afternoon our
guest for about the next 35 minutes now
Noam Chomsky professor of linguistics at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology we've seen the numbers at the
bottom of the screen and we ask if
you've called in the past 30 days to
wait so that others can get on with our
calls a little bit more easily first
call us from Royal Oak Michigan good
afternoon
yeah you know you started talking about
NAFTA and you got me thinking about my
my first objection to it was just the
fact that it was like 2,000 pages and
you know it's just it's like you don't
you don't really understand it and you
think they're trying to fool you with
something and I was wondering how long
did bills used to be like a hundred
years ago and do you think that you know
it would be possible for them ever to
just see all future bills should be less
than ten times the length of the US
Constitution well you're quite right
about the not only the length of this
but if you do have a look at it you'll
find that it's also unreadable I mean
it's uh it's very hard going and recall
that this was it was intended that this
would be rammed through in secret
if you look at what happened the
agreement was signed by the three
executives of Canada United States and
Mexico in mid-august 1992 I think was
August 12th or so 1992 remember that was
right in the middle of a presidential
campaign whatever one thinks of attitude
towards NAFTA Chavez has a big effect on
American life try to look back and find
out what am I said about it nobody was
very little discussed if I probably
wouldn't been mentioned at all of Perot
hadn't brought it up nobody knew about
it nobody knew what was going on
according to US trade law there's a 1974
congressional legislation which requires
that any trade related instrument any
law or whatever involving trade must be
submitted to the labor advisory
committee group based in unions as for
advice and consultation and analysis
that's the one popular input to trade
legislation it was not given to them
they were in fact informed that their
reaction to NAFTA was due on you know
let's say September 15th or whatever the
date was some date around then and they
were actually given the text of this
2,000 page document on readable document
24 hours before the due date that was to
ensure that they couldn't even formally
convene all of this incidentally was
oppressed in the press nobody talked
about it the labor advisory committee
did write a very detailed and rather
interesting analysis and they were very
bitter about this and pointed out that
even the procedure was a major attack on
democracy the intention was that all
this would go through Congress was on a
fast-track they weren't going to pay any
attention to it
and nobody would know there was enough
popular opposition that developed for
all sorts of reasons so that it had to
become a public issue but it was not
intended to be it was intended to be you
can see by just what I described it was
intended to be driven home and secret
and then just sort of sitting there
locking into place particular
arrangements and particulars of the
powerful and as I mentioned it itself is
quite anti-democratic in its essential
nature so your your
your reaction to the length of the text
and furthermore the complexity the text
is quite accurate and when we fill out
more details we see that that's a large
part of it in fact I think it should men
of the major impact of these of these
developments including yet may well be
to undermine democratic structures and
to transfer power to private private
power essentially private transnational
institutions and recall that a
corporation is essentially free from
public control and when it becomes
transnational even the limited control
that comes from national legislation
declines you are a professor of
linguistics
what is linguistics and what's two parts
and what's the significance of its study
well there's a lot of covers a lot of
territory but the kind of linguistics
that we do is an effort to find out the
basic principles of a certain part of
human cognitive nature what is it that
enables us to to do what you and I are
doing what special thing is it about our
brains as distinct from other organisms
that enables these extremely complex
systems of Arctic of the creation and
articulation of thought and interaction
first of all to develop why do they have
the forms they do what are the
principles they operate under what
aspects of them are universal just
rooted in our genes basically which
turns out to be most of them and what
does this tell us about the nature of
the human mind I mean that's essentially
the topic Cherry Hill New Jersey good
afternoon
gosh I wish would stop dissecting every
part of the United States in the world
why don't we go to a 25-hour we work and
we could all go out and smell the roses
what's so bad about that
well actually proposals with that kind
were made by not for 25 hours but I
think 36 hours or something by the Union
it's years ago and that's a very it's a
very interesting question remember the
fight for a 40-hour week was a huge
battle it took almost well about 70 or
80 years of
very bitter strife and in the United
States very violent strife I should say
I think about 700 workers were killed by
security forces during that period
simply to attain the 40-hour week and
shortly after that victory was attained
that started being lost so the 40-hour
week is now a thing of the past the
average work week has been increasing
through a variety of mechanisms since
that victory was won the question of
whether there should be a lower workweek
is it should be you know it in my
opinion at least I mean here values come
in but in my opinion it should be
basically a matter of democratic
decision but of course for it to be a
matter of democratic decision that means
that corporate power has to be under
Democratic control if the decisions are
made by private power unaccountable
private power they are naturally going
to try to drive their workforce down to
the lowest possible level and get the
maximum out of them and if that comes
from having 60 hour weeks so dry for
that Garden Grove California good
afternoon
yes I wanted to ask mr. Chomsky if he
believes that if there are no changes
made and the way we trade and operate
internationally whether this wouldn't in
the long run reduced the world to global
serfdom and then it seems were right
back to where communism came in in the
first place if people cannot survive
they're going to repeal and here we
spent 40 or 50 years fighting communism
and we seem to be moving in to the
direction where we're gonna get it back
thanks for the call well there's a lot
to say about what we call fighting
communism for one thing there's no
plausible sense of the word in which the
Soviet Union was communist or socialist
or anything like that it was a
totalitarian state which was from its
origins radically opposed to any element
of the traditional socialist vision but
whatever it was this was a big part of
the traditional third world which is
essentially what Russia and East Europe
were within Europe's third world had
been for hundreds of years which went
off on a course of independent of
which we call communism and they called
communism that we don't allow parts of
the third world to escape from their
service role it doesn't matter whether
they're little ones or big ones and that
led to a big conflict they are now back
in the third world that's what losing
the Cold War means and I don't think
it's a I mean the the revolutionary
changes that took place in Russia were
indeed a reaction to their deeply
impoverished third world conditions they
had nothing to do with socialism or
anything like that but that's what they
were you're right our effort to destroy
it was not an attempt to to improve
economic conditions in fact take a look
at the parts of the third world that we
do control that takes a Brazil you know
huge rich country with enormous
resources which we've been had a big
strong hand and running since 1945 and
take a look at it that's what we've been
trying to create in a third world it's a
country with a sector and five or ten
percent of the population of great
wealth the average level of the country
is about at the level of Albania or
Paraguay
then maybe 75 percent of the population
lives in utter misery and this is in a
country with an enormous advantages and
no enemies tremendous resources of lotta
US aid and in fact US tutelage since
1945 and my suspicion is that's what
much of Eastern Europe will come to look
like but you're right about the the
tendencies that now exist are polar or
polarizing tendencies much of the world
indeed most of the world is the society
is becoming polarized on an
international scale with these there's
low growth in most places there's
increasing wealth but in very small
sectors and substantial parts of the
population are declining they have to be
controlled by force in my opinion it's
kind of symbolic that the anti-crime
bill passed a couple of days after NAFTA
passed
I mean after NAFTA it's going to have I
think it's fairly clear this polarizing
effect meaning more people more social
disintegration meaning more crime
meaning more force because unless
something constructive is done to
reconstruct society you're just going to
control people by force and will it
ultimately lead to rebellion or I think
it probably will I mean in South Central
Los Angeles is a case I wouldn't call it
a rebellion it's a break out of some
kind but it's a response to and these
are @xa South Central Los Angeles I mean
these are regions where there were jobs
at one point there was industry when
that disappears you get social
disintegration which can take all kind
of forms I mean abuse and families for
example alcoholism random violence I
mean take a lot of forms it could
possibly take constructive forms and I
very much hope it will and those
constructive forms order the efforts to
reverse these tendencies which are
deeply rooted in the international
economy Lagrange Indiana good afternoon
yes dr. Chomsky I'm a student at Purdue
University and I would just like you to
know that you've been an inspiration to
me academically my question is how would
you like to see President Clinton
respond to the growing nuclear threat of
North Korea I would like to see serious
efforts against proliferation and
looking at North Korea alone does not
really respond to that issue first of
all the question of North Korea and is
in a broader context but bear in mind
that while Clinton is talking about nuke
the threat of nuclear proliferation in
North Korea he's also contributing to
nuclear proliferation so one of his
grand achievements at the asia-pacific
summit was to override congressional
restrictions on sale of high technology
equipment to China now those
restrictions were imposed by Congress
when Congress was given what they
considered conclusive evidence that
China was involved in missile
proliferation possibly involving North
Korea incidentally and possibly also
nuclear proliferation and if you look at
Clinton's summit decision it was to give
them supercomputers which is Pentagon
analysts quickly pointed out can be used
for missile development and nuclear
development and also to allow US exports
for
nuclear power generation now nuclear
power generation and nuclear weapons
production are very close and since
China has we can believe us intelligent
been engaged in proliferation
essentially Nixon was a Clinton was
saying that I don't care about
proliferation what I care about is
profit for US corporations there are
other cases to I mean one of the major
nuclear powers aside from the really big
ones is the State of Israel which is the
CIA pointed out decades ago has hundreds
of nuclear weapons well you know its
nuclear capacity is as an element in in
the world which has a lot of people
frightened I don't see any concern about
that when you turn to North Korea I
think the problem is real and I think
it's a problem of how North Korea is to
be integrated into a world system in in
under conditions in which it is at the
moment pretty desperate and pretty
unstable and that issue goes beyond
nuclear weapons it looks to me as though
North Korea is kind of desperately
trying to trade some form of potential
or maybe actual nuclear weapons
development against a form of acceptance
into the international system and I
think that's the direction that should
be pursued the last call would say a
student what kind of a teaching mode do
you still carry regular teaching alone
at a place like I teach my graduate
school so it means well I don't know
maybe several hours a week of actual and
lecturing and many hours a week of
person-to-person interaction with
students Plus and you've been teaching
for how many years let's seize thirty
eight years I guess all the words named
after nearly forty years
what do you still like about the
classroom it's really exciting I mean
the there's nothing more exciting than
the intellectual interchange
the interaction with students whether
it's in chill I at one time in my life
actually taught children not teaching
advanced graduate students and it's
always an exciting experience or it can
be McLean Virginia good afternoon good
afternoon dr. Chomsky two questions
number one have you written another book
since deterring democracy or do you have
another one in the works yeah several oh
great for in fact I'm a little bit on
them they're kind of hard to find you
know yeah well let me see if I can
remember them I'll listen for a really
fast year 501 rethinking Camelot
Chronicles of descent letters from
Lexington and prosperous few and the
Restless many or what come to mind great
how are you said they're they're hard to
find
well they're usually not on the Shelf
per se or you have to special order them
in terms of being able to get them I'd
you know I don't like to wait around for
things to come in I just like to see
what's on the shelf and they're not
they're a little bit on the scare side
they're also not reviewed so it's hard
to know about them and they're usually
published by small presses which don't
have the resources to advertise okay one
other quick second question in terms of
looking at the mass media these days you
don't really see much contrary opinion
real contrary opinion when you're
looking at the major media and it's good
to see that at least you get out every
once in a while I caught you on Posner
and Donahue a while ago and what what do
you think in terms of getting more
descent in terms of real contrary
opinion into the media do you think
that'll be happening or how does that
work
I wouldn't think it it's not on its own
it won't happen I mean the media are
basically huge corporations which sell
audiences to advertisers and they're
going to reflect the interest of their
owners and their buyers by and large
however as popular pressures develop you
know as popular organization takes place
and in popular involvement in the
political system and in social change
and so on the medial respond to it I
think you're quite right that there's
more openings now than there were say 30
years ago at least I experienced that to
a limited extent and I think it's just a
result of the changes that have taken
place in the country
it's a more active lively vibrant
society than it was 30 years ago and
this is reflected in the media to some
extent while you're but why are your
books are defined
they say unpopular things so the of what
one book of mine happens to be on the US
media it was a best-seller in Canada it
was literally a best-seller
it was based on lectures given over
Canadian Broadcasting Corporation I
don't think it had a single review in
the United States why should American
media want to publicize a critical
analysis of the American media San
Francisco good afternoon
yes hi professor Chomsky I want to let
you know that I was at the premiere of
your the documentary about you premiered
here in San Francisco and I thoroughly
the new audit my question for you is now
that the historians are starting to
speak about the 80s and the Ronald
Reagan presidency I'm not so interested
in you know what you feel about Ronald
Reagan more what would you feel the
continued effects as we head into the
next century are going to be and maybe
speak to the conditions that brought
this about well the Reagan II I think
you're right in putting Reagan aside I
don't think I think he was mostly a
symbolic figure probably didn't even
know what policy was most of the time
but the the policies that developed and
occur in the Reagan years were in fact
continuations of the late Carter years
so if you look at the last few years of
the Carter Administration Carter
introduced called for vast expansion of
the military budget and cutback of
social programs though he didn't have
quite the political clout to push that
through
but the Reaganites pushed it through and
in fact the military programs of the
Reagan years are not all that different
from the projections of the Carter years
same with the cutback of social programs
and this goes back to things that happen
in the early seventies and when there
were big changes that took place in the
International System one of them was
that Richard Nixon dismantled the
Bretton Woods system the system of that
developed after the Second World War of
International sort of capital regulation
in which the US was in effect the world
banker that said that was one of a
number of factors that said into in
motion a substantially in fact huge
growth of speculative capital in the
world of accelerated the
internationalization of production
meaning you know shifting of production
abroad and that sort of thing and set a
lot of other forces in motion this meant
a sharp attack it meant lower growth
sharp attack on welfare and living
standards and wages wages have been real
wages in the United States have been
declining since about that time in fact
and the Reagan years simply extended and
accelerated these differences so the
Reagan years were years of substantial
polarization maybe 70% of the population
its actual absolute wealth declined in
the Reagan years whereas for the top few
percent they became greatly enriched and
this just is a continuation and indeed
acceleration of the kind of processes
we've been talking about and unless
there's there also going on in the
Clinton years and unless we the
population does something about them
they're gonna continue Syracuse good
afternoon dr. Chomsky yeah it's like Sam
bong admired work studied it here at sir
cheese University I was wondering how
you feel NAFTA will affect third world
countries particularly these countries
in Central America spoke earlier on
third world economies well of course the
Central American countries technically
already in NAFTA but the and it's a
little hard to predict there was a what
was called a Caribbean Basin initiative
which was going to include the Central
American countries and the Caribbean
countries and that was that the policies
of the central of the Caribbean Basin
initiative were what are called
liberalization I mean those countries
are to open themselves up to market
forces now that has a general and NAFTA
will probably in the long term
contribute to opening up third-world
countries to market forces now there are
a lot of
rich countries don't allow themselves to
be open to market forces so the United
States is highly protectionist it has
all sorts of systems for a massive state
intervention in the economy and it
always has every successful developed
country relied from England up till you
know South Korea and Taiwan relied on
including us it relied on radical
intervention state intervention to
protect economic power from market
forces and it continues until this day
the Pentagon system for example
economically speaking is just a funnel
by which the general public subsidizes
high-tech industry which is of course a
radical violation of market principles
however the third world's to be deprived
of those mechanisms so that it will in
fact be a kind of service area and the
effect of these programs there have now
been so-called structural adjustment
programs there have been well over
seventy five and them I've forgotten how
many exactly the general effect that
they have is to lower Labor's share of
national income that's the overriding
effect I mean then what happens you know
depends on one place to another but they
themselves have this polarizing effect
and that's the way market forces work we
have here a mixture of market forces and
state intervention and the state
intervention is for the benefit of the
wealthy fact you want to know how it
works have a look at Clinton's great
triumph in Seattle the this sort of
centerpiece which got so much hoopla was
a speech that he gave in which he
announced his vision for the few free
market future in the Pacific and he
picked a model company which he called a
model for what other American
corporations should do and if I gave the
speech and and a building of that model
company a hangar of the Boeing
Corporation that was the model for the
free market future Boeing is a publicly
subsidized corporation Boeing relies
extensively even for its existence on
the Pentagon if it wasn't for the
Pentagon funnel Boeing would not be the
country's major exporter and cracker
would be functioning and the same is
true of the aeronautical industry
altogether
the same is true of the other we
mentioned crazy super computers would
you know being given to China why decree
super computers exists because the
public paid the costs of research and
development for computers and in fact
provided substantial part of the market
through the whole Pentagon system the
Pentagon NASA and so on these are the
kinds of interventions in market
processes that benefit it's a certain
sector of the economy the more skilled
professional investors top managers and
so on as far as Central America is
concerned though they're going to be
subjected to market forces in fact we've
done this Costa Rica in Central America
was the one exception to the Central
American model of almost total social
disaster remember this is the region of
the world where we have had the most
influence we take a look at Central
America we learn a lot about ourselves
that's where we've had enormous
influence because proximity for a long
long time there was one exception to the
disaster that the harder' chamber that's
most of the region namely Costa Rica
which for various reasons had developed
the kind of Western European sort of
Social Democratic character and was a
much richer country than the rest well
you know during the Reagan years there
was a pretty harsh attack on that Costa
Rica's there was a lot of pressure on
Costa Rica to abandon its social
programs to cut back on domestic
investment to open itself up to market
forces in fact to become very much like
the other countries of the region and it
largely succeeded the United States a
pretty powerful country especially a
relative to Central American countries
so the fate for Central America and
after our know NAFTA in my opinion is
unless again unless we do nothing about
it because they're not powerful enough
to do it themselves is to become
essentially export platforms for
American industry which will use
extremely cheap and repressed labor for
profits here and elimination of jobs
here Gainesville Florida good afternoon
professor thanks for Yuri
visit here to the University of Florida
I'm a student in philosophy down here I
appreciate your talk I especially
appreciated the time about the Florida
State University mascot I said that was
appropriate my question is this
certainly we expect each individual to
make up their own mind about issues and
not make up their mind based on their
political affiliation but what was
unique to NAFTA that allowed for
individuals like say yourself and Pat
Buchanan or say Bob Dole and Bill
Clinton normally on other sides of the
political aisle to hop into bed together
so to speak well NAFTA was an
interesting issue I mean it was it was a
very overwhelmingly it was a class issue
in fact the New York Times even
permitted itself the unusual phrase
class lines which was rarely a term
which rarely appears in the media
because it's a little too revealing but
they did point out that the attitude
toward NAFTA by and large broke down on
class lines corporate power was
overwhelmingly for it business and
corporate power was overwhelmingly for
it the work force was overwhelmingly
against it the media were overwhelmingly
for it but they automatic almost
automatically respond the corporate
interests that despite the enormous
media barrage virtually 100 percent
approval the general population remained
somewhat against it so the latest polls
I saw I think in september/october
showed about of the portion of the
population that had an opinion it was
about 55 or 60 percent opposed which is
something that had stayed pretty steady
as for Pat Buchanan and Ross Perot they
were a little bit exceptional usually
they take a corporate to stand on this
issue they didn't for whatever reason I
think you'd have to look into their
particular point of view and motivations
but you're right that's a funny Alliance
Los Angeles good afternoon hi mmm
professor Chomsky I just took the class
this semester at Chapman University I
had a question I was wondering where do
you think how and who do you think she
regulates the content of the media Janet
Reno was just in
Congress speaking about how TV violence
should be stopped do you think that the
companies the media itself could control
themselves or do you think there should
be a regulating force governmental force
behind it
well I'm personally very skeptical about
any form of regulation of any kind of
speech now the media don't even begin to
approximate freedom of speech I mean
this is the kind of freedom where people
who own the place set the rules so
that's not real freedom nevertheless
the idea of X even in that kind of
system heavily skewed towards extreme
wealth personally I'd be reluctant I'm
very reluctant to see any kind of
regulation take place freedom of speech
is a really important value we've over
the centuries we've particularly in the
United States won a lot of leave one
substantial freedom of speech and I
think we ought to preserve it however
with regard to the media I think there's
a much more serious question should the
media be democratized I mean if the
media are our institutions of private
power we can be quite sure that they're
going to have have a particular take on
things they're going to give a picture
of the world which by and large reflects
the interests of their owners and their
advertisers and other centers of power
in the society and that means that the
attitudes and points of view and
interests of the general public are
going to be marginalized and I think the
answer to that is not you know
regulation its democratization the
specific question of violence on the
media - Hardman I I think you have to
have a balance between which is not easy
to just determine between allowing full
freedom of expression and imposing some
restrictions on what people are exposed
to so for example even the most
passionate advocate of freedom of speech
does not believe that say I have a right
to go into your living room and put up a
pornographic poster or something that's
an that's you might say my inability to
do that it's a restriction of freedom of
speech but I think everyone agrees with
that when you move to a safe posture in
Times Square saying
some obscene thing or this graceful
thing the issue becomes more complex
because it's not really private space
it's just the space where you are and
the conflict between the right to
private space and the right to freedom
of speech begins to be ambiguous when
you go to the media becomes even more
ambiguous it's in a sense private space
I mean that's given the way the society
is you just kind of you know you're not
compelled but you're at least driven to
being exposed to it and therefore what's
on it is kind of involvement in your
private space but at a more remote step
it's at this point that values become
difficult than decisions become
difficult however my own bias at least
would be against now I think the but
that the burden proof has to be on
anyone who wants to introduce any form
of regulation in my opinion Washington
DC good afternoon hi professor Chomsky
I'm also a fan of yours I read at least
five or six dear books and many of your
articles over the years I work quote
within the system here in Washington DC
I have for about ten years and I was
wondering your perspective on the
election of Bill Clinton over George
Bush and whether you think there's any
positive difference whatever for either
the American people or people
internationally of his being elected
there is some difference between what
Bush represented and what Clinton
represented I mean Clinton was
essentially a what's called a moderate
Democrat that I mean a kind of a
right-wing a pro-business Democrat a new
a new Democrat and that means it was
very difficult to distinguish that from
moderate Republican but there were some
differences if you look at the campaign
for one thing the Republicans and
Democrats have rather different
constituencies the Republicans are quite
openly the party of business you don't
pretend to be much else the result is
that they don't really appeal to a
popular constituency the way the
Democrats do they by and large have to
appeal to a constituent public
constituency on the base
of jingoist appeals fear religious
fundamentalism and so on you could tell
it from the Republican convention and
that's a substantial part of the
population and that the Democrats on the
other hand put themselves forward as the
popular as the party of you know the
working people and the ethnic minorities
and women and so on in fact in practice
they're just another more or less
another business party but the
difference in constituency shows so when
these parties are in power although the
major decisions that they make keep to
the essential agenda of the state
corporate Nexus which doesn't change a
lot on other issues which are of less
significance to a major private power
and they do different things so on
issues of say civil the the Reagan
administration and Bush as well carried
out a very substantial attack on civil
rights and I would and and that harms
the interests of the popular
constituency of the Democrats in fact
the general public and I would expect
then I think we already see a slight
difference in that respect things like
say limited amount of family leave which
every just about every industrial
country has in fact far more than we
Bush vttitude Clinton passed it again
that's a sort of throwing crumbs to the
constituency these crumbs are not minor
incidentally with regard to how what our
lives are like but they're very minor
with respect to the major interests of
maximization of power and wealth so if
you read say The Wall Street Journal the
main Business Journal you'll find
they're very enthusiastic about business
and about Clinton and described it as
one of the best candidates big business
could imagine despite the fact that on
say social programs and other things he
may not be entirely to their taste there
were there was also a difference that
you could detect on major economic
policy the Clinton administration called
much more openly for state intervention
to support and protect major economic
centers than the Republicans did the
both they're all protectionist the
Republicans tended to be a bit more
ideological about it and not to
intervene not to call so openly for Thor
so extremely for intervention to protect
business from market forces the Clinton
called a bit more for that in fact it's
done a bit more so Clinton's national
export strategy announced in late
September called for an extension of
policies that the Reaganites and Bush
had pursued which were in violation of
CAD as everyone admitted and Clinton
wanted to extend that and it was put
rather well by the Secretary of Treasury
Lloyd Bentsen who said something like
good I'm tired of this level playing
field business I want the playing field
tilted more toward the interest of US
business so we always tilt the playing
field in the interest of US business but
they wanted to tilt it a bit more
Buffalo New York good afternoon hi good
I'm a graduate student and I'm
interested in educational history and I
think that like the media higher
education has played a role in
reinforcing corporate interests and I'm
wondering do you believe that higher
education in the future is going to
become more democratic or less
democratic depends on what people like
you do about it
if there is no popular involvement in
this private power will have its impact
which is significant and that's gonna
make it less democratic for the
universities and the whole educational
system to be more democratic there has
to be some counter balancing force to
private power and that only
counterbalancing force can be public
involvement in democratization so to the
extent that such forces exist the
universities can become more democratic
in fact they have become more so in the
last 30 years in my opinion we have with
just a few seconds left you've written
so much already and you mentioned
earlier three or four books in progress
what do you hope comes from your
writings my hope is that it'll stimulate
people to try to ask questions about the
world and
find their answers I mean I have what I
think are my answers but I think if
people have a broader range of analysis
and information available to them
they're in a position that come up with
better insight and better understanding
or at least so I hope and then of course
I hope they'll do something about it
because just having the ideas in your
mind doesn't change the world Noam
Chomsky is professor of linguistics at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology thank you very much and we
thank you for your calls in your
comments have a good afternoon